Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire.
I've been sitting in for David Pakman today and
hey, folks, you know what we really dislike? We
dislike socialists here in the United States, or
at least the Republicans do. Right? Everybody that
is their opponent gets smeared as a socialist.
It's socialism, even though most of them couldn't
even tell you what the word means. Everything
they hate is a socialist or communist or fascist,
even though again, they just use those words
interchangeably because they think that they all
mean the same thing. Well, now Republican Senator
Marco Rubio, who is up for reelection this year,
has primaries actually today. And he's
going to win because he's the only one.
He is being smeared by one of his
libertarian opponents as a socialist.
And maybe smear is not the right word. He's
being attacked by his libertarian opponent
as a socialist. Libertarian opponent by the name
of Demas Dennis. Excuse me, Michigan. Miss Igwe,
my apologies. I've mispronounced that. But either
way, Mr. Michigan. Said in a recent interview.
That Marco Rubio was a socialist.
Now Marco Rubio is many things but a
socialist. I never thought I would see the day
where somebody would accuse him of being a
socialist. But then I read this article. That
was an interview with Mr. Ms.. Igwe. He actually
makes a good case, and I typically don't say that
about anything that libertarians have to say,
but he makes a damn good point. Let me read this.
Rubio is pretty uniquely bad. No argument from
me there right off the bat. You got my attention.
Not just in the sense of being unpopular and easy
to dislike, but policy wise. This is a guy who
got elected as part of the Tea Party wave back
in 2010. And when you listen to him talk about
dealing with issues of economic policy, it's all
central economic planning. It's not free markets.
I would characterize him by the Republican
standards as a socialist. Is he a socialist?
By the means of seize the means of production
to nationalize everything? Socialist?
No. But is he a socialist? A socialist by the
Obamacare? A socialist standard? I'd say, yeah.
Okay. You're losing me a bit
there because Obamacare is
in fact not socialist. So going to
have to, Dana, on that one, Mr. McCoy,
he continues, though Republicans have long
presented themselves as the champions of fiscal
responsibility, smaller government and whatnot.
I really got turned off to them in the first
part of the 2000. George W Bush was president for
eight years. For six of those eight years, you had
Republican majorities in Congress. And what they
do with the spending and the growth of government.
Well, we all know. Right. Government grew.
Spending grew. Deficits grew. All of that
because Republicans are bunch of socialists.
Now, I think what Mr. MRGO was trying to get at
is that Republicans believe in corporate
socialism. Right. That's what you want. Because
Republicans love to spend money. They love to give
money to corporations. We love to prop them up.
We love to bail them out. We love to give them
subsidies and tax cuts just for the heck of it.
So in that regard, yes, there's lots
of socialism here in the United States,
most of it at the hands of the Republicans going
directly into the pockets of the big corporations.
So in that regard, if, of course, that's
the point he's trying to make here,
if that's what he's calling socialism on the
behalf of Marco Rubio, I agree with you 100%.
Now there there does come a point where I
disagree with him, not about Marco Rubio, but
about something else he said in this
interview. Because then he gets back, you know,
to his libertarian leanings, he makes a couple
good points. He makes a couple confusing points
that make no sense, as I said, with the Obamacare
thing. But then he goes back to his libertarian
ways, which never make any sense. Here's what he
said. We want the market to be as efficient as
it can be because an efficient market delivers
goods and services to people at the lowest cost
possible, lowers the cost of living overall. That
makes it easier for people to live. And it leaves
more capital left over for people to create
new things that improve people's lives further.
Boy, I wish I lived in the fantasy
world that you live in, Mr.. Mr.. Goofy
because literally none of that ever happens, ever.
And that, of course, is my big problem with these
libertarians. They're living in a fantasy land.
Well, if we just let corporations do whatever,
of course they're going to take care of people.
Of course they're going to lower prices. Hello?
What? What on earth like? What drugs do you have
to be on to make you have visions of this world
where corporations inherently do the right thing?
They don't. Even with government agencies that
are supposed to force them to do the right thing,
they still don't do the right thing. What I would
encourage all of these libertarians in the United
States to do is go get a job at a plaintiff's
law firm and work there for at least a year. See,
I've worked with a plaintiff's law firm, including
actually other law firms all throughout the
country as well, for almost two straight decades.
I have seen some of the worst documents
imaginable. From every industry imaginable.
Whether it's the tobacco industry, the
fossil fuel, the chemical industry,
food companies. They will literally never do the
right thing unless they are forced to pay up for
it. And when that happens, they typically only
do the right thing while they think people are
still paying attention, then they go right
back to doing horrible things. So again,
libertarians, I beg you, read some corporate
documents, then get back to me on whether or
not you think corporations will inherently
do the right thing for the American public.